how big is the fortune of russian
president vladimir putin and how did
putin a lifetime public official
accumulate it those are the mysteries
forbes has grappled with for 20 years
figuring out putin's net worth is
probably the most elusive riddle and
wealth hunting but that question is more
pertinent now than ever as president joe
biden weighs leveling sanctions against
the russian president for his actions
near ukraine admittedly we don't know
the size of putin's fortune but over the
years leaning on sources and expertise
we've developed some theories
in 2002 we ran a cover story by forbes
russia founding editor paul klebnikov
profiling a rising russian oligarch
named mikhail kordakovsky
at the time his company yukos accounted
for 17 of russia's oil production and
was believed to have significant
influence in the kremlin he was worth
3.7 billion dollars and was russia's
richest person by october 2003 he was in
jail convicted of fraud and tax evasion
which he denied there was little doubt
that putin was behind his arrest the
freezing of his fortune and the eventual
breakup of his company kordakovsky's
fate was a powerful lesson to other
russian oligarchs but the question
remains how much of kordovsky's fortune
did putin take for himself
bill browder an american financier who's
conducted a lot of business in russia
has a theory putin forced the oligarchs
to give him 50 of their wealth or he
threatened to take all of it and throw
them in jail if that's true based on
that math browder calculated in 2017
that putin was worth 200 billion dollars
which would have made him the richest
person in the world at the time
browder's calculation was simple add up
the net worths of all the russian
oligarchs and divide by two
russian billionaire peter aven who heads
russia's largest private sector bank
lent credence to that theory when he
told robert mueller as part of his
special counsel investigation into 2016
election interference that he was one of
50 russian business people who regularly
meet with putin at the kremlin the
mueller report states quote even said
that he took these meetings seriously
and understood that any suggestions or
critiques that putin made during these
meetings were implicit directives and
that there would be consequences for
aven if he did not follow through
this theory is that putin's fortune
comes from helping his close circle of
friends and family become rich by
awarding them government contracts or
ownership in businesses
in return the theory goes he gets
kickbacks of cash or stakes in the
companies in some ways it sounds like a
mafia structure whereby soldiers in this
case billionaires are in perpetual debt
to a boss in this case putin they do the
dirty work he takes a cut
among the putin cronies who have grown
extremely wealthy his former judo
sparring partner arkady rotenberg with
whom he reportedly still plays ice
hockey received more than 7 billion
dollars in various state contracts in
the lead-up to the sochi olympics
earmarked for everything from a power
plant to the development of ski resorts
more recently rotenberg whose brother
boris and son igor are also billionaires
called himself the owner of a huge
complex of buildings on the black sea
coast which russian opposition leader
alexi novani called putin's palace
[Music]
in short given the lack of evidence
otherwise it's possible putin has little
money of his own and simply likes people
to think he does because it suggests
power putin's official financial
disclosure released annually by the
kremlin lists his 2020 income at about
140 thousand dollars the only assets he
claims ownership of three cars a trailer
an 800 square foot apartment and a 200
square foot garage plus the use of a
1600 square foot apartment and two
parking spaces
no mention of his sizable collection of
high-end wristwatches or putin's palace
which he denies he owns let alone the
massive portfolio of palaces yachts and
aircrafts he uses as russia's
unquestioned leader
in the end putin may not need money so
long as he has the appearance of having
it and the power that it would otherwise
confer as putin bullies and threatens
ukraine one can look at this model and
hope that in the end it's just more
bluster
[Music]
you